let's talk a little bit about saving and
investment and investing so one thing
that you'll hear me talk a lot about how
is how important it is to save one it's
a sign that you're living sustainably
that you're spending less money than
you're bringing in
and it also allows you to bring build a
cushion if anything bad were to happen
if you were to lose your job or there's
some medical expenses that are
unforeseen or whatever it might be
having that extra cushion is going to be
really really helpful really helpful
it's going to lower your stress level in
a lot of ways the other valuable thing
about savings is it allows you to do
certain things that you wouldn't be able
to do if you didn't have it for example
put a down payment on a car or buy a car
outright or put a down payment on a
house you need to save your money in
order to do it and that last category of
buying a down payment on a house one it
might allow you to live in the house
that you want but you can also view that
as you're making an investment you're
buying a real asset in real estate and
not only is by put buying that asset you
will save on rent in the future but the
house itself might appreciate and so
savings allows you to also invest
obviously you could buy a house you
could buy rental properties other forms
of real estate you could buy stocks and
bonds bonds you're essentially lending
money to some group you could buy
treasury bills treasury bonds that's
essentially lending money to the U.S
federal government
you'll get better interest on that than
if you just kept your money in a
checking or savings account and a lot
better interest than if you just put
your money stuffed it in the mattress
where you'll get no interest and but if
you want to take on more risk you could
buy stocks stocks are your buying shares
of a company and a lot of folks will say
oh you'll get you'll get better return
there but there's also more risk there
stocks can go up and down pretty
dramatically depending on what's
happening with the economy depending on
how people are valuing these things but
the bottom line is savings is a great
start it builds a cushion and then you
can use those savings and you can think
about how you might want to invest it
when you invest you should you should
never think that you're going to get a
high return without any risk there's
usually a bit of a catch there but
investing is a way that if you invest
prudently you should over time hopefully
bring in more money than you are putting
in and so one way to think about that is
you're taking your savings and you're
getting your money to work for you for
your money to create income that you
yourself don't even have to work in
order to produce so if you save enough
money and you keep investing it in in
thoughtful ways that aren't too risky
that money will grow and eventually
might be able to create more income than
you can on your own so it's a pretty
good place to be if you can get there